my next guest is a facebook
vice-president and one of the most
powerful women in the UK tech industry
but back in 2016
Nicola Mendelssohn's life changed when
she was told she had an incurable type
of blood cancer when Annika is launching
a new charity the follicular lymphoma
foundation to help raise funds for
research into a little-known cancer
let's face it Nicola joins me now Nicola
hello I'm follicular lymphoma and you've
got one of the biggest jobs in the world
you've got a big family you felt a lump
you went to the doctors and all of a
sudden you knew this term you knew this
type of cancer talk to me about the
diagnosis and what happened well first
of all thanks for having me on in you're
right nobody's ever heard of this sound
so nobody can even say that yes
follicular lymphoma but it was was
actually three years ago to the day that
I am first discovered a lump in my groin
and didn't think much of it but as I
called my doctor and she basically said
well if it hasn't gone in a couple of
weeks come and see me and so I did go
and see her and she sent me to another
doctor and so begins if you like the
conveyor belt of diagnosis and actually
unusually for blood cancers I was
actually diagnosed within a week I had a
CT scan I had a biopsy and then I was
told I had follicular lymphoma and it's
often met with blood cancers you can get
symptoms I didn't have any apart from a
lump sometimes you can have night sweats
you could lose weight you can feel tired
and as a woman you can often get them
you know don't worry that's the
menopause or something like that it
wasn't the case for me and the case for
me was that I was diagnosed in a week
and then I had that moment of well you
know in your head when you hear cancer
you think well I've just got to beat
this now I'm gonna blast it what's the
treatment B I cut it out exactly and
actually with this cancer and other
blood cancers there's an option where
you can just watch and wait and see what
happens for awhile where the doctors
monitor you but there's no point in
actually treating you early because they
can't cure you and so they try and hold
back the treatments for a later date
which is what I did
incurable watching wait what does that
actually mean because at the moment
after three years your
in remission but presumably because it's
incurable the danger of it coming back
never leaves yeah that's right so it was
actually I was in I did watch him wait
for 18 months and then last summer I had
a scam that showed her that it was
growing really near my kidneys and they
said at some point it would give me
kidney failure so I took the decision
then with the doctors that I would need
to have chemotherapy and immunotherapy
which I did for for six months that's
what put me into remission or the
technical thing is no evidence of
disease now the cancer is still there
it's still mutated on a microscopic
level and at any point it could flare
back up it could be a year it could be a
week it could be ten years there's not
enough research of knowledge to know at
this point how it will how the path will
be yeah the foundation wants to make the
invisible visible raise awareness of the
symptoms get more research into it
because I suppose the assumption is
because it's very rare there's not a lot
of money that goes into finding a cure
yeah that's why I think blood cancers on
the whole I've got quite a low awareness
although together they're the fifth
largest cancer killer in this country
and last in the last couple of years
there was only nine million pounds spent
on these 5060 different cancers so of
course you're not going to find a cure
if there's so little money going in you
know so that's why I wanted to make a
concerted effort to set up this
foundation to set up the charity and
ultimately hopefully to find a cure not
for the hundreds of thousands of people
that are living with this all over the
world Nicola you're a very impressive
woman we talked about you being you know
one of the the biggest people in tech
outside of Silicon Valley so you have
one of the biggest jobs in the world you
have a big family you've got four
children various different ages a
husband your schedule is gosh time to
the minute throughout the year talk to
me on a personal level that what it was
like to get this diagnosis and be told
it was incurable how did that put your
life into perspective look it's him it
was a massive shock I mean it just it
was a physical shock as much as an
emotional shock I can sort of still feel
it that moment all the cliches that
people talk about how you sort of feel
sick to your stomach and your life sort
of flashes by you and you all sort of
the dreams and hopes that you saw and
you imagined because you know you kind
of think you're a bit invincible don't
you and there's suddenly you you know
you see that it really there's a
different future
that first weekend was was horrendous it
was very very dark very difficult not a
crying lost I lost half a stone in
weight in just crying and worrying and
stress and not telling anyone because I
didn't want to tell anyone till I knew
exactly what this it wasn't it your
son's 18th week yeah who was coming up
for his 18th so wanted to let him have a
nice 18th birthday not not worry about
what this was all going to mean but I
but I actually took a look at my life as
well and thought actually I'm very lucky
and I'm very blessed to have the things
that I do have that I am supported by a
great family a great husband that I do
love my job and so I thought that's not
how I'm going to approach this cancer
I'm going to do it in a different way
this is what earned you the tag
superwoman because obviously well when
your diagnosis became public he were
very open with your employers Facebook
about what you were dealing with and
they said take as much time as you need
as any good employee would but you
decided the best course of action for
you was to carry on as normal as it were
and keep your high profile job to the
same level that you had before why did
you decide to do that because a lot of
people would have said oh you need to
take a step back reassess recover let
your body here or what was your
motivation yeah I think it's a really
personal thing and as I said I love my
job I really enjoy what I do and so to
have that in no way taken away from me
would be well you know what are you
doing like stripping me of all these
different things and I didn't want the
cancer to define my life it's not that
haven't made changes I have made a
couple of changes in terms of my diet
and exercise and things like that but I
didn't want to lose all the things that
part define me as well and in terms of
living with it day to day as I said as
we sit here you're in remission now
which is great news but how do you deal
with it day to day so I get strength
from this from a Facebook group that I'm
in called living with follicular
lymphoma and there's 6,000 people in
that group now and so you've got people
at different stages of the journey and I
remember when I first heard in the group
and there was somebody in there that had
had been in remission for 10 years he
thought how is that possible you know
it's incurable how can you be there and
they talked in this post about some days
they don't even think about it at all
anymore I can't be possible
you know when you see
the word counselor is so
front-and-center actually sometimes I
don't think of it every day and then I
sort of remind myself and go oh it is
still there so I think it is possible
and it definitely takes the ability to
compartmentalize one thing versus
another but you know the good days I
don't think about it and the bad days I
try and stop the mind wandering to you
know the bad things as to what could or
might happen I try not to go there yeah
and there's pressure on employees isn't
there in a company whether it's small
medium or huge like Facebook to keep
their personal life away from work
there's a lot of pressure that by you
putting it out there and being very open
about your diagnosis and what you were
dealing with do you think that's helped
other people not just you know employees
but businesses as well to see that you
know something like this can happen to
an employee and it can be managed you
should be more I hope so and actually
I've heard a lot of correspondence from
people telling me that actually gave
them the kind of encouragement to go and
share their stories I had one girlfriend
who I didn't know had breast cancer but
been hiding it from everybody including
her employer and I saw when she came and
sort of whispered and told me and I said
what are you worrying about and she said
what I was worrying about whether they
would fire me which I guess is a real
worry and of course most people are not
like that most people are human and it's
actually how can we help is the thing
that actually people turn around and and
I do think there is a taboo around
illness I really think that's true in in
the workplaces and certainly at Facebook
one of the things that we encourage
people is be your true authentic self if
you're if you're trying to put masks on
top of your you know what you're doing
anyway you're never going to be the best
version of you so I would always opt for
being open and transparent did you find
anybody treated you differently
yes some people in in the early days
would come up to me and they just look
sad at you they sort of tilt the head of
you and sort of nodding and so you about
to die and home sorry and then you sort
of make apologies to them don't worry
I'm okay right now but on the whole I've
just found that people have been really
helpful and just really lovely and they
take their guide from you as to how you
act and sometimes because I'm really so
I've not mentioned it's like that's fine
yeah that's okay not it not to mention
it you want to have some sense of
normality that worked at you
want to get on with it at home what's
that been like because we touched on
your children there and we've got a
gentleman coming in later on who's
written a book it's this childhood grief
awareness week this week about how to
talk to children about uncomfortable
subjects like that what was that like
for you it was hard I definitely did
research beforehand as to any advice
that I could how you tell children that
mums got cancer
it was hard what we decided to do John
and I is to actually bring the kids
together and tell them all together in
one go rather than doing individual
conversations it was yeah it was the
hardest it was the hardest conversation
I've ever had and now you're keeping
that dialogue going with them because
it's always on their minds as well as
you yeah it is and they said things like
we forget that you've got it mum because
you seem normal and you seem like you're
just out there but every now and then
and it's you know especially this week
launching the foundation it's very
present and front and center but I guess
it's part of all of our lives now and
that kids are in a good place and we've
been juggling incurable cancer setting
up this foundation family life one of
the biggest jobs in the world
as I've said your role at Facebook is
pretty full-on and as you are battling
this there have been a lot of battles to
fight a Facebook as well because while
you were having a turbulent time so is
the company in its evolving standpoint
on things like fake news harmful content
and data security so you've got to keep
on top of all of this as well and what
if we just talked a little bit about
political advertising you'll have seen a
few weeks ago Twitter announcing that
there was gonna be a blanket ban on
political advertising a blackout which
is the polar opposite of what seems to
be Facebook's approach which is a
anything-goes policy what do you think
the right approach is so I just want to
be clear that we don't have an
anything-goes policy we've got really
clear rules and community standards
there anything that goes on our platform
whether its advertising organic has to
adhere to that said we do allow
political advertising on our platform
which is different to Twitter the reason
for that is that we believe that in in
an election or in any given period
people want to have the opportunity to
be able to discuss and debate and to
scrutinize what politicians are saying
and I think that in a democracy they
don't really want an a private company
to be saying what should and shouldn't
be put out by politicians so we think it
should be put out there and then people
can debate and discuss it what we think
is also important is that if people that
if politicians are doing advertising
with us they have to register with us
first and then on the it's labeled on
the top when you see the ads when they
come in your newsfeed that it comes from
that political party and the
transparency comes by the fact that we
then take all those ads and we put them
in an ads library anybody can go and
check out that ads library at any point
and actually in this election it's the
first time we're seeing it being used
where you can actually see what ads are
being targeted at who and how much has
been spent do you think that policy your
ad policy will evolve more because the
one problem I suppose with a Facebook ad
libraries it could be more transparent
it shows you how much is being spent but
it doesn't show you where it's being
spent who's being targeted how they're
targeting those people using Facebook
and also fact-checking ads as well so
parties can put up an advertisement and
it goes completely unchallenged okay so
there's a few different parts in that
question first off within the ads
library you can go and you can see who
it's being targeted at and actually with
the only platform that actually offers
that sort of transparency if you want to
there's no way that you can go and see
what the leaflets are being put through
people's doors or or what adverts were
running in the press or even in posters
even last week so all this now exists on
in Facebook and will be there for seven
years so you can constantly go back and
check and see what people are doing so
I'm proud of that I'm proud that you
know that we're doing that but you know
there's always more that we can be doing
and we're always iterating on our
platforms as well so I'm pleased with
the progress we're making there oh but
what about the fact that a political
party could go on and put a video that
has outright lies I think you know news
outlets for example Sky News is under
more scrutiny than ever before for
accountability fact checking balance and
it seems that politicians party is on
Facebook can say whatever they want
uncheck it again and I think people have
a
problem with that if you see something
on Facebook how do you know that it's
true so if there's anything I'll know
that could cause real-world harm or
could impact in any way the you know
people going out to vote that would come
down that would have no place on our
platform want to be really clear about
that if something has been labeled in
the past as if as misinformation that
couldn't be used in advertising but
other than that yes it could be out
there and then part of that is what we
see happens anyway in the natural course
of an election is that people will
discuss it people will debate it and
then what it does is allows the public
to form proper full opinions of the
different messages that different
political parties are putting out there
deep fakes is something I actually
learned about first on Facebook and it
was a clip of a Saturday night talk show
where comedians face had been replaced
with Tom Cruise's face and the
technology was such that you couldn't
notice the transition and that's a real
concern now deep face not just because
of you know light-hearted comedy moments
but in terms of you know putting words
in the mouths of people you know that
aren't true what a face book doing to
challenge deep faiths because of course
that technology is extremely advanced
and extremely new so one of the things
that we we're doing a lot more of is the
investment that we're making into
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and it is almost like if
you like an arms race against the bad
guys that you know will bring in some
tools and they'll break you know they'll
move again and so we will as well
we've also traveled the number of people
that are working in this area around
safety on our platforms to 35,000 people
over the last couple of years as well
and the total summer monies that we're
spending in this whole area to combat
these sorts of things with
misinformation false news is actually
more than the total revenues of the
business of Facebook when we went to IPO
so that's billions and billions of
dollars but we're not going to be sad as
we know we've got to keep investing here
because we know these things were
important talk about Facebook learning
and evolving do you think Mark
Zuckerberg will ever change his stance
on political advertising because it is
such a tricky issue in terms of you know
people talk about free speech and people
being able to make up their own minds
but it's so nuanced a lot of political
advertising if it's not outright lies
it's forming people's opinion and
algorithms and the weight gets to
somebody is so complicated do you think
that he would change his stance in terms
of not an outright ban but have more
stricter rules in the future I think
where we are is where we are at the
moment and what I see though and the
reason it really matters and it's
important is because it also gives voice
to the smaller political parties that
are trying to break through as well you
know the big parties they've got voice
they've got the reach but actually the
smaller parties and especially you know
in the election that we're seeing at the
moment I think people are very
interested and so you can't just band
for one and not the other that's why we
want to have that platform to allow all
the parties to talk that's just a
snapshot of the huge pressures you face
at work and at home we've talked about
that what's next for you as we said
you're in remission you're doing well
busy at work what's next for Nicola
Mendelsohn well the I've never really
looked at things like that the way that
I that I think about things is am I
still learning am i enjoying what I'm
doing and then well then I'm a lucky
person well Nicola he certainly has been
really interesting to talk to you learn
more about follicular lymphoma good luck
with the foundation thank you for
talking to us about and the many issues
associated with Facebook at the moment
it's always a pleasure to talk to you
thank you